[Music]
it's cool to go back to those games that
were so brutally hard as a kid where I
couldn't even beat the first level and
learn how to absolutely destroy the
games
it took me very very long time to even
be able to beat Super Mario Brothers for
instance and now I have the record of it
[Music]
you may know me as Darby and on Twitch
my name is Brad and I'm the world record
holder in Super Mario Brothers the goal
of speedrunning is to go fast
it took me six thousand six hundred and
seven tries to set the record I can feel
my heart going kind of crazy in my chest
I get a little uncomfortable
I might notice my hands sweating more
I'll get antsy I'll hit a button too
early or too late or I'll try to play
too perfectly
because I say I may never get another
opportunity like this I better not blow
it let's go all out I think you need to
be a very patient person to speed run as
you come closer and closer to reaching
the goal like you get later and later in
the particular run these thoughts start
going through your head could this be it
I hope I don't screw this up the neat
thing about speedrunning is that the
expected outcome is failure and the
better you get at it the more you fail
that was the game med suit 30 seconds
off of the record
[Music]
the Mortal Kombat games are some of the
most iconic of all time round one flight
and when you're winning nothing is
sweeter than hearing these words
sucia but what man could be so even
suited to channel such a demonic voice
feel the power of my name is Steve
Ritchie and I'm a pinball and video game
designer in the early 90s Steve was
making pinball machines in the very same
building a couple of guys were
developing the second Mortal Kombat game
upstairs was pinball down stair video
development Steve did the voices for a
bunch of pinball machines he designed
most of the time I do I do bad guys and
this is the voice that I have and it can
be I am the black difficult ac/dc of
devil I'm on the highway to hell so when
the Mortal Kombat creator needed a new
voice for the announcer he knew what
right where to go and pulled Steve into
the recording room and he started
telling me say it like this
fatality you would say no more breathy
roar
Ecology all this victory that little R
had to be wrong lately okay round one
fight oh that was it oh yeah if they add
the effects even the lower pitch fiducia
well cool okay Johnny Cage wins
Mortal Kombat has spawned a dozen video
games comic books TV shows and a film
franchise featuring this awesome techno
song
but see his contribution to Mortal
Kombat isn't what he's known for its
pinball because Steve he's made a lot of
pinball machines I've created more
pinball machines than anyone else in the
pinball history but whether he's a voice
in a video game or designing a pinball
machine the thing Steve loves most well
we'll let him tell you I like to put the
player in a spot of an adversarial
relationship a battle you're beating
your ball snatching and into things to
experience normal combat we know it's a
video game but when he says something
it's like round one fight it's just like
he's scary and and you are battling this
guy hey Steve hey Jim just kidding you
should do it Steve
finishing this one quiet
[Music]
all the machines in this arcade homemade
there's something magical about all this
as a child as I found that making things
that made people laugh was satisfying
and seemed more point in doing that and
making useful machines
[Music]
I'm Tim Duncan and I'm a cartoonist and
engineer I have two arcades
one on the coasts and appear and this
one in central London called novelty
automation in total I suppose I made
about fifty machines not many people
have that as their ambition in life but
yeah it's six feet this is pet or meat
you spin the wheel and you find if the
land ends up sitting with you on the
sofa or being carved for dinner it was a
hobby that got out of control
this is Auto frisk you stand in front
here the gloves inflate and then they
act you down Britain's got a great
history of satire and I suppose I'm not
really particularly political myself but
I think it's healthy for little people
to poke fun at the rich and powerful you
fly this little drone around this
Beverly Hills mansion and see all the
stars inside and your paparazzi you have
to try and take the photos to fill up
the cover of the magazine I get my ideas
from lots of places it's partly things
happening in my life partly things
happening in the news and partly from
old arcade machines and mechanisms this
is test your nerve you have to put your
hand inside the cage with the mad dog or
as long as you dare
to do something like this you have to
enjoy the process of making things I
spent most of my life solving
conventional engineering problems rather
than thinking up the jokes this is the
chiropodist you have to take off your
shoe for this one you put your foot in
the treatment bay down the bottom and it
feels really weird seeing people
enjoying using the machines keeps me at
it
and also because they take money it
provides the income to let me keep at it
so to me it's a pretty perfect system it
sure beats working I never planned my
career or anything about my life it's
just occasionally a sort of opportunity
comes up and then I go through it was
the game that coined a dozen
catchphrases and made over a billion
dollars reporters maybe a jam almost
never saw the light of day
[Music]
this is NBA Jam game designer mark
Turmel so we put together a demo
videotape VHS we send it to the NBA and
said hey we're making this cool game and
they immediately shut it down and said
no we don't want the NBA logo in the
arcades so once we got rejected we made
a video tape of nice family
entertainment centers and we sent that
back to them and said look you know this
year logo can be here so they relented
and provided the license when we put it
in the arcade for the very first time
there were no staffs that differentiated
the players everybody assumed that Shaq
was a bad three-point shooter or
Stockton could steal the ball so we
realized pretty quickly that we had to
you know up our game to match the real
world well if it's just looking at pure
attributes I happen to be the best
player in the game when you actually put
in my secret character it just shows
question marks for the stats but they're
all tens or nine I'm pretty good at
Nvidia to test the claim we have more
attack into the machine there we go and
turn on cheat codes and now we're
talking usually when somebody finds out
that I've made NBA Jam they say I spend
so much money on that NBA Jam or you
know I flunked a class in college
because of NBA Jam well I look at the
game now
I wish it were smoother but it was the
technology at the time
the game still holds up today
[Music]
Mario to me Mario
wha-hoo Nix ago okey-dokey oh I've been
the voice of Mario for 26 years now
forgot who we do hi I'm Charles Martin a
I do the voice of Super Mario Luigi mine
ha ha and Mario hey borrow today
yeah oh you gonna eat that garlic and I
was even Donkey Kong one boy who I am an
actor and voice actor I did gosh 25
years of theater corporate videos a
circuitry and semiconductor processes a
few film and television products now
beat it all you know and then that I had
the marvelous beginning of becoming a
voice actor and that's how I started
with E to me Mario Mario was first
created in 1981 in a game called Donkey
Kong as it got refined through the years
it became Mario and Princess Peach Dean
says and I came along in 1990 I actually
crashed an audition because I was
catching them as I walked in they were
walking out finished for the day
I said can I read for this and the guy
looked at his watch and goes alright
come on in
you're an Italian plumber from Brooklyn
a character in a video game for Nintendo
called Mario so make up a voice make up
a video game start talking and I thought
to myself video game I don't know
anything about video games and all of a
sudden I hear action I go hello I'm a
Mario let's make a pizza by together you
will get some sausage I'll get some
spaghetti we put spaghetti in the
sausage in the pizza and he said you
know cut
stop talking there's no more tape all
right thanks we'll be in touch and I
thought that was you know okay there's
the door we'll see you later and I he
calls Nintendo I found out Mario I got
him and that was 26 amazing fantastic
years ago
I know I know we'll be oh look at this
for the character for me brings out the
best in me and so I I love that I love
sharing things too I go to meet Mario
fans and I hear the most wonderful thing
you know the you're the voice of my
childhood you know I used to play with
my dad now I'm playing with my kids you
know and we just it's a way our family
comes together back the memories yeah
you just have fun you know that's my
mantra for life come on let's go it's
have more fun bye bye see you in my
games is what whoo
you
you